[Music]
what is
beautiful my glorious lovely people my
god-given name is rich roll
once again i'm here joined in vulcan
mind meld with my
sine wave sibling adam skolnik waterman
writer lover
not my lover just a lover in general so
far how's it going
yeah so far we'll see our relationship
is developing
if you're going to put it that way then
you're right yeah um
how are you i'm good man before we get
into all of that though let's just do
the preferatory stuff
for those of you who are new roll on is
the special
limited edition version of the show
where adam and i
prognosticate on matters contemporaneous
matters current
confounding complex self-evident
non-obvious obvious we typically
buttress all of that with a bit of other
you should know
we share a few wins of the week we round
it all out with
some listener questions that we answer
uh if you're interested in
that throwing your hat in that ring you
can leave us a voicemail at 424-235-4626
with that out of the way adam how
are you i am really good
life is good uh no complaints
wait i shouldn't i'm not supposed to
wear a jacket a gentleman always wears a
jacket to podcast
i'm not only wearing a jacket i'm
wearing tie-dye because i just got off
my shift at
ben and jerry's no it's a it's a it's a
conundrum your contrast
it's confusing i got the formal jacket
but then
the hippie well that's my thing i am a
walking
contrast in styles that's what i'm going
for that is that
that's the intention behind all of this
you know how everyone's like just when
you think you've got a grip on adam
yeah she's like everyone is going with
like the cool like
understated tie-dye the new tie-dye i
went with the
audacious like ben and jerry's tie-dye
fish that's where i'm going fish exactly
fish with a pea
fish meets uh i don't know what
brooks brothers wall street what's going
on yeah it's like if
trey anastasio did take a job at an
adventure
take that job instead of pursuing his
life's passion but still
was holding on to that sensibility fish
only became like a bar band in like the
in the east village right well they all
like yeah well they worked
wall street jobs during the day yeah i
think who knows
they chose the right career i think
career path
trey anastasio uh shout out who's right
i think that's the second time his name
has come up i wanted to
come up maybe with jessa jess leahy i
can't remember his name came up
previously i once saw a fish
show at a gym in vermont
in like 91. that was the first time
and so it was pretty early days for them
and then they became of course
you know the second biggest jam band
ever when i was in
law school in upstate new york it was
all about fish like 90
92 to 94. yep uh
big time fish community
uh we're talking about music later in
the show we are so we're already getting
into the bands
i know but go ahead tell me about what's
been going on with your
latest swimming escapades oh yes i uh by
the way hank wise wants to get all up in
your kitchen
and involved with hank wise you left us
a voice we did
we left we're not going to answer his
question today but i appreciate that
hank reached out
to a friend of mine and i appreciate
that he was um
he he was giving me my permission to
wear my own mask it's
exactly correct um and
and he wants to go for a swim and i'd
love it man but he was talking about
great white sharks if
later in that voicemail um and so
basically i
i don't know if you saw on if people who
follow me on instagram
um i posted the second time now i've
been out with carlos g the malibu artist
at uh where one of my swim spots not the
one i go to
to dive but just an open water swim spot
which has been known it's also a surf
spot
and it's kind of known to have a kind of
a shark nursery offshore
um well he has been there now twice two
weeks in a row the first week he flew
when we were in the water he saw a shark
but we were about getting out of the
water this time
uh there was you know there was a 10
foot
white shark 30 to 50 feet from me while
i was swimming
and uh the funny part of that is he has
a whole protocol so if
if you're swimming and all of a sudden
you hear the drone zoom by your head
and then it's hovering and then you stop
and you look and it's hovering above the
water
there's a shark right beneath it that's
his signal for get out
that's his signal it's not a get out now
because in this case the shark was
between me and the beach
that's not good
that's not good and the best part was he
was flying right near
the stand-up paddler who had no idea
what was going on so the stand-up
paddler is all of a sudden trying to
swat the drone away
not really but like he's like annoyed by
the drone were you
at zuma where was it no this was
temescal so
the shark you know that there is a storm
drain
just south of the bel air bay club and
that's where the shark was so
wow i had been swimming and i just
started to do some
um intervals and so you know i'm
splashier because i'm trying to go
faster at least the way i do it it's
splashier
and uh and all of a sudden i i see the
drone i hear the drone i see the drone
and i'm like splash here is not a good
idea right now yeah
so i just stopped for like a minute and
watched and then i thought and then
he shot the drone up which is his signal
that he's lost the shark
and he's looking for it again and i just
thought okay well i'm here to swim with
him
and the reason is i know it sounds
stupid and even me when i saw the drone
hovering there i thought okay this was a
cute idea
but now it's real and um and
you know but why am i doing it and the
reason i'm doing it and the reason i've
always been okay to do it
is because these sharks have been there
it's not like he just it's not like
they're there because we're there
they've been there or all of a sudden
they showed up right they've been there
all along
just our ability to detect them right
improved
right and so they've been there and
there is no as far as i've researched
no history of attacks in that area
they're not looking for us
there are dolphins that come by they're
looking for them there are sea lions not
in that spot but there are dolphins and
you know
so i've always known that and so my
feeling is
that they are not interested in us
that's the point of what carlos is doing
i mean yes there's a danger there but
what he's doing is not
what shark week does which is to
sensationalize a lot of stuff and oh
you might get attacked you might you
know even those guys involved in shark
week love sharks and
they're not trying they're they want to
push a shark conservation narrative
and he does too and so his you know what
he's doing is raising awareness that
they're there
and it's not like you shouldn't be
mindful of it he's not suggesting that
but he is but he is showing that the
odds are low that you're going to have a
problem
extremely low i mean if you think about
how many people are in the water
and how close they are on a regular
basis he did a
um a drive up the coast from malibu to
ventura
and he saw over 20 in one day wow right
off
right behind the waves right so this is
not
a new right but still that may be his
intention but when you see the image
it is you know you have a you know a
very kind of like guttural physical
reaction to it because that
shark was big it was i mean it was legit
and it was not that far away from you no
and so
i just don't know how you get back in
the water
and swim relax like you can do it and
rationalize it and say they're not
interested in us
they're offshore maybe he's there maybe
he's not is this an enjoyable exercise
for you because for me
i just start getting preoccupied with
that and it's very difficult for me to
just
enjoy myself and and kind of let go well
i was gonna i'm gonna do
because i posted it in stories i'm gonna
do a proper post and talk about it but
um
so my feeling is when i was in the water
yes i was with you i was all of a sudden
i was my
my antenna was up and i wasn't so
relaxed but
my heart rate didn't really spike or
anything either and i will go back to
that spot
and swim and because i'm just not that
worried about it
about getting hurt people should know
like
this is the beach that extends from the
palisades to santa monica it's a pretty
trafficked beach where the beller you
know bay club like all of these like
beach clubs are along there like
there's a lot of people the sand is very
wide there yeah
but you know there's a lot of people in
the ocean
in that area it's not an obscure hidden
beast no i mean stretch of the
imagination sunset
surf break is right there it's probably
the busiest surf break in
in the in you know the entire la county
i would think maybe
that or topanga yeah and um and they
don't know
they're not they're not familiar with
how how many are right there
um you know we saw one time april and i
were driving back from malibu and we
were driving right along that
that where the the highway comes right
up above the kind of rocky
ledge that leads down to that surf spot
and we saw a white shark i saw splash
she'd seen the white shark breach and
this time um
while we were getting ready i was
getting suited up he said he saw white
shark breach he was certain of it
i didn't actually see the splash i was
facing him um and so i knew going in
that there was a shark there
so it's not like i didn't know and um so
i knew going in but i still had a very
relaxed
opening part of the swim when i saw the
drone i'm not going to lie obviously
i did feel like you know like nobody
wants to be the guy
if the shark was between you and the
beach how did you get back
to land so i continued my swim which is
you know i
i tend to swim three to four hundred
yards
offshore so my first part of the swim is
to go out
and then i go along the coast and then
there is a
buoy off of the air bait club that if
i'm just gonna do like an 1800 yard swim
that's kind of what i do
and that's like a you know 35 minute
swim and i swim around that buoy and i
came back
but this time i swam around that buoy
and i came back outside
because how did you know that you
weren't gonna just run
right into the shark well i wear a mask
for a reason rich
um i didn't know uh you never know i
didn't
bring up the mask by the way no i i um
i didn't know but i came you know i i
just kept my eyes open and i just
decided to
to you know at that point i decided to
relax
um i've been doing it a while i've been
swimming in the ocean very regularly
since 2012.
uh i've been
in the water with big animals before i
think i've gotten to a point where i am
not over it completely i don't think you
ever get over the fact that sometimes
that boogeyman is going to just flash in
your mind you're gonna remember you're
in the
you're part of the food chain right now
and there's nothing really you can do
about that
yeah um but uh for the most part
it's kind of out of me now so i don't
feel it like when i show up at the beach
i don't get nervous
i don't i don't think about it on a
regular basis all right
so i don't know but nobody wants to be
the guy that gets eaten by a shark on
youtube i can assure you
no nobody wants that and you know after
that big speech
now all eyes on adam if something should
befall you
yes meanwhile somebody's jackhammering
out here i don't know where that's
coming from i hope that's not too
distracting but suddenly we have like
crazy
uh construction happening right outside
our door yes
uh anyway um tell me about this
uh thing with louis pugh louis pugh hall
of fame
open water swimmer um known mainly for
his swims in antarctica he's the first
to swim
in a riverine like a in a glacial melt
he's a legend we've talked about him
before haven't we yeah we have when he
did
the antarctic the most recent antarctica
trip i think we talked about it um he
was planning
uh and is planning to swim the the width
of a fjord
the mouth of a fjord in greenland to
raise awareness because what he does is
he does these
incredible open water swims in freezing
water
and he uses it as a platform to then try
to push for
um nations to to align and change uh
to solve the climate crisis uh and so i
was the plan was to be in greenland with
him
in august and do a story on his swim
there
and then his attempt to bring it to
glasgow to the un climate conference and
to
motivate uh other countries to get on
board and start to fix these problems
because
as we know we have wildfires we have i
mean
every day you can find climate crisis
news whether it's called that or not
um on july 27th uh there was
a melt in greenland which is not the
biggest they've ever had but enough to
have covered
all of florida and two inches of water
that's how much ice melted in one day
it's the third biggest i think ever or
uh
one of the top three anyway we're gonna
go do that
now his swim is in jeopardy because the
delta virus has gotten into greenland
uh greenland did really well in their
initial phases of the virus they didn't
have many cases they haven't had any
deaths but they only have 12 ventilators
in the entire country and delta is
already there so they shut down
commercial flights from reykjavik which
is
the best way to get there um they make
it
it's very hard to get in there right now
so it's unlikely that i will go
i'm hoping he still can go and do it um
but i'm waiting to hear and if
if i can make it i'll be there not for
the times right who is
this this is going to be a long reads
it's like a long deep dive story on
lewis and and his attempts to
you know move the needle in russia and
and china
mainly russia he's connected to um a
senator there
uh sergey fedesov who is a
hockey legend and so they've become
buddies and
and um trying to push russia who tends
to be one of the people
one of the countries dragging their feet
russia and china have vetoes on a lot of
this stuff and they drag their feet on a
lot of climate issues
um and they don't necessarily vote it
down but they don't vote yes and so
you need a consensus on a lot of these
issues so he's pushing
um countries all over the world he's
lobbing them but russia if he can get
russia to move in that direction would
be
so huge so um yeah that's cool yeah he's
been doing this for a long time yep
and there's nothing like you know
performing a swim in these crazy
freezing waters to unite you know
opinion around the issues and create
consensus because who's not going to
celebrate
you know something like the things that
that that he goes out and does and
and he's extremely eloquent yeah he's
like i don't know is he a
is he a former lawyer he's he sort of
conducts himself like a
he's much more of like a statesman than
an athlete
like he's an environmentalist first and
foremost he's an activist
um but he's about consensus building and
kind of
creating um creating you know policy
change
at the highest level and you know not
just sort of waving a flag and
making a stink but actually getting
parties together yeah
produce results he's al gore that swims
yeah basically yeah that's good
much easier way of saying in certain
certain respects yeah cool
um well i hope that i mean first of all
i hope that he's able to do it second of
all i hope that
that you could find a way to get there
and cover it i mean
if they're they're not letting people
into greenland how many people live in
green life
so they're letting like a thousand
people a week in which is
are there more than that many people
that want to get into yeah because it's
summer season it's like people go
like it's like there's crew you
know there's like there's also there's a
whole business and there's
people that live there but apparently
all those flights are booked and they're
out of copenhagen
so i've been trying you know i i'm
waiting for him to
he was gonna try to charter a flight get
approval for a charter
to come in from reykjavik but he did not
get approved for that or at least not
yet and the clock is ticking because
after september 12th
it's extremely unsafe for him to swim
there so there's like a
a time where the air temp is going to
get so cold
that he wouldn't be able to recover
after a swim and the way this swim is
going to go it's going to be about a
kilometer swim each day
um and then he gets out and then he
starts again the next day so it's not a
straight channel swim because he's in a
speedo
and a swim cap and it's 37 degree water
yeah
so you know all that ice they talked
about that melted it's going right into
that
right yeah so wow yeah uh
unbelievable yeah well cool more to be
revealed on that
yeah how are you man i'm doing okay i'm
a little
uh i'm spaced out man i'm having trouble
with my brain forming thoughts so if i
if i blank out it's all on you to carry
this podcast i'm essentially kind of a
little overworked
trying to get the next volume of voicing
change done
while also balancing everything uh with
respect to the show
going out of town tomorrow to colorado
for a wedding so trying to get
everything tied up before i leave and
julie's already gone so dealing with
kids so i'm a little i'm a little
afraid at the edges to be honest with
you not uh
maybe not my best self today but i'm
doing okay
but i'm coming in to this podcast a
little bit fast and loose i feel like
last time we did three hours
yes and the outline was very laden
and i felt very um wed
to the outline and today i'm like i
don't have time for this
let's just come into this and and see
what happens yeah jettison is better
anyway
just be more present rather than like
staring at an outline yes
um not that we don't have some idea of
what we want to talk about
we're outlining funny we're not pantsers
we're not going to read
not reciting scripts i did want to
mention
this is curious and interesting okay the
reaction to
to last week's podcast with bruce
friedrich at least on
on uh on instagram in the comments below
my instagram post was like out of
control
like they're almost i don't know how 280
maybe 300
comments below okay the post just saying
this is
you know here's bruce he's been this is
first of all it's the third time he's
been on the show
right so these are not new this is not
new terrain
um but people had a lot of strong
opinions about it there's a certain
sector of the community that felt like
i have betrayed my roots that i should
be talking about
whole food plant-based diet and getting
people back in sync with nature
and you know uh talking about organic
and non-pesticide and how can we live
within
uh you know the kind of cycles uh the
circadian rhythm of the planet
how can we you know we should be
focusing more on regenerative ag
and repairing our soil instead of all of
these new cultivated meat products that
are being called franken foods that are
filled with chemical chemical laden was
a big kind of phrase that got thrown
around and i just think that
do we know your no i mean i think just
because it's like oh
this is a big food and they're making
synthetic frankin food
right what is this we should be
repairing our soils of course we should
be repairing our soils this is not
an either or situation it's not a binary
issue
no basically yes we need to pivot
towards
more regenerative agriculture and away
from
factory farming and animal agriculture
we need to repair our soils we should be
eating organic we should be finding
you know better ways to you know to grow
food out of the land and make that
accessible and convenient for everybody
at the same time we're dealing with
environmental problems and
sustainability issues
and um issues around
uh this is where my permission brain fog
is coming in
no over over like compassion basically
the suffering of
animals right and there's a gigantic
swath of the global population
that essentially uh is subsisting on a
fast food diet they're going to drive
throughs and they're eating the cheapest
food
possible so the whole cultivated meat
thing
and the innovations that are happening
in plant-based meats etc
this is not being directed at people
that are already converted to a whole
food plant-based diet
or who are all about regenerative ag or
who are growing their foods this is
oriented towards creating
an accessible cost-effective
convenient solution that has a better
ecological footprint and is more
compassionate than the current
options available to those people so we
need all of these solutions we need
people looking at
how we can you know
create more nutritious food with less
resources we need to figure out how to
pivot away from animal agriculture we
need to do
all of the we all solutions are needed
and so i just thought
the the kind of dialogue or debate that
was going on in the comments there
it's fine you know have at it everybody
but you know just
to be clear just because i had bruce on
doesn't mean that
i no longer believe in these other
things right i've had you know all i do
is talk about
eating a plant-based diet or pivoting
people towards more nutrition you know
nutritionally dense
foods and all of the like so just
because i have a conversation with
somebody on doesn't mean that
i now am disavowing uh you know the
other people that i've had on the show
right it's a conversation it's
interesting this is happening
it's actually happening in the world so
let's talk about it
help me to understand it and all these
these comments are from people that
clearly didn't listen to the podcast
because all of the things that they're
concerned about i raised and we
addressed right
so anyway well it does affect me i
really should
like post and ghost and not pay
attention to this stuff at all like i
have this tension because i want to be
engaged in the community
right and i do care what people think is
this one
landing for people is it not um but
ultimately
like maybe we'd all be better off if i
just turn the comments off or
you know figured out a way to not look
at them at all because
you know you don't want to turn it off
because the engagement is
is it helpful to anybody is it well
that's a good question i mean you know
we get
does anybody read you know get into the
comments of anything on youtube or
instagram and go my life is now better
as a result of every other day i go on
everybody's instagram site and i try to
pick a fight do you
good how's that going for you
that i was pro friedrich it's pretty
easy to do that you can get into a fight
without even trying to get i have
four ghost accounts so i can't now i
know what's really going on
okay um
you know uh i think it's good to
we need to in general be able to have
discussions
with people and about things that we
don't agree with
and if if we can't do that we will never
advance
well what's funny is that people say to
me why do you have all you have all
these people on that you agree with why
do you have people
on that you disagree with okay well
within reason like i don't need to
have somebody on my platform that i
completely disagree with and
i don't feel you know merits that level
of attention
right right but then when i do have
somebody on like bruce like
i have concerns about cultivated like
what is this like how is this going to
imp you know like i have
legitimate concerns about that so i have
somebody on who
i agree with a lot of what he has to say
i have concerns about other things and
then i get
um criticized for having somebody on
who doesn't align completely perfectly
with my values or the values of the
listener so what do you what do you
really want other people that
that have different points of view or do
you want to tune in and just
hear somebody regurgitate like your
world view over and over and over again
to affirm what you already believe
i think i think both of those things
but mostly it's the silo you know that's
the problem with being siloed in so i
i what my point was is kudos to you
for inviting someone on and the reason
you invited him on your platform is
because you know he's
got um his point of view is this could
be
this could benefit everybody it's not
just this will benefit me
and listen if you're gonna you've got if
you're gonna solve problems at scale
there's compromises with that you need
to work within the system you gotta get
tyson you gotta get
cargill you gotta get these huge
companies interested in this so this is
why i was
this is why i'm interested in paw
hawking and aquaculture and
and the the the benefits of aquaculture
that's why i'm not
you know when we had our seaspiricy
debate that's what this exact
same place i was coming from is like you
know we do have to think
there are other people eating and
they're not necessarily all going to be
down with the
diet that that right you know you're
choosing and i choose
most of the time you're not going to
solve the world's problems by
by uh browbeating people into changing
their personal habits right
and if and and so you have to be able to
feed those habits to some degree
because and you can you can move them
you can it's like but you need to meet
them with an
alternative that is just as convenient
just as cost effective
tastes just as good is as nutritional
nutritionally valuable and and created
with
a lower you know footprint and all the
like all that
right yes but i don't know i don't know
how we got down this rabbit hole i mean
the point is i think this the other
point i want to make is
that comment sections you know on social
media sites
are not necessarily a proxy for the true
you know audience temperature on a
certain thing it's just you know people
have strong opinions they want to voice
them and you know whether that
it you know truly reflects the majority
take on
that podcast i think if you start to
align those things you're
going down some dark alleys
anyway there you have it i just i'm
trying to give myself my own therapy
on this yes and the good news is you're
going to tell your ride
i am so yeah you know for a couple days
to get some fresh air yeah
um all right let's pivot what do we want
to talk about
enduro corner yeah this is this is
colorado this is where you're headed
well we could just follow up on on two
things that we talked about last time
we've been uh keeping you up to speed on
ravi ballenger's colorado crush
for those that are new he's in the midst
of this summer long quest
to conquer a variety of
ultra challenges that include the
leadville marathon
he rent he then ran the colorado trail
which is 500 miles he did the silver
rush 50 back in leadville
now he's in the latter stages of of
summiting all
58 of the colorado peaks that are over
14 000 feet called for 14ers i think
he's done
33 as of yesterday we're recording this
on monday
so you know just uh uh you know 25
more or what have you and then he's
going to rock it out with the leadville
100 to complete the whole thing
on august 21st so seemingly having no
issues and just out there every day
taking cool photographs of you know
climbing all these mountains
so good for him right driving around in
a you know one of those like sprinter
vans
is he sleeping in the van i think so i
think they got it all kitted out
yeah i've seen it it's amazing um which
is cool he's living it man he's on the
mission
i mean i don't know much more to say
other than that you know he's done 33
and he's
you know continuing to kill it but we do
have an update on timothy olsen
since we last spoke he completed the
pacific
crest trail uh the fkt was achieved
fastest known time he crushed it uh the
previous record was
was carol sabae i think that's how you
pronounce that from belgium in 2016 he
did it in 52 days
eight hours and 25 minutes timmy did it
in
51 days 16 hours and 55 minutes so
by a decent margin by about 16 hours
yeah a little less
we're talking about 2653 miles with 40
000 feet of elevation gain he's running
51.3 miles a day on
average for seven weeks straight i mean
given all that
like that is he did crush the record
anytime you beat a record by
hours it's amazing but at the same time
it's like it was narrow enough to where
like any one problem could have
trashed derailed it yeah yeah yeah if
you had one significant problem yeah
yeah it would have jeopardized the whole
thing
yeah no small feat my friend
congratulations
you should come back on the show and
tell us about it yeah i know there was
some
improvisations due to trail closures and
the like where they had to like you know
figure out how to jockey around certain
sections that were closed and get to a
different
i don't know exactly because they have
like wildfires right which i think is
why
that might be why the kind of official f
key
if i keep saying ftk it's fkt
i make that mistake a million times um i
don't know because of that
because of ftp or because of ftp i don't
know
yeah stp stone temple pilots it's
because of stp maybe it's because of
that
um so i don't know if it's official i
don't know what makes it official
maybe it's pending right now but i think
it will be official meanwhile his wife's
eight months pregnant
you know it's been this spiritual
journey for him i mean timmy's a very
soulful guy
i think part of it was processing you
know the the kind of grief that they
shared over two
miscarriages that they suffered through
um but that was one hell of a baby moon
bro
i know no kidding yeah you've redefined
the man the man baby moon
his coach is uh jason coop who i know a
little bit
i met jason when i helped crew for dean
carnaz as a band
at bad water because jason helps coach
dean and jason's a great you know he's
just a great resource for
wisdom uh when it comes to endurance
training and he wrote a really cool kind
of blog post with his
takeaways from timmy's performance
because he he coaches timmy as well
uh and i'll link that up in in the show
notes it's beautiful yeah man
what else you got saif syed uh our
friend that we met
in utah during the iron cowboy final
days he's the uh phd student in
ai right that had never run a marathon
and showed up and just started banking
marriage
he moved from texas where he was
studying to utah and his buddy's
guest room and started showing up every
day and then he went back home didn't he
he's not still hanging out he's back in
texas and he
his goal was after that he was inspired
to do a 50 miler on his birthday which
he did accomplish
so kudos cool and on that note
um i think we officially have a date for
the iron cowboy coming on the podcast
beautiful
he's gonna come down here i don't
remember when not not right away it's
gonna be a little bit i think he's gonna
come with sunny too so it'll be both of
them spectacular should be cool
um he he reached out when i posted the
shark video the shark photo
oh he did what did he say he said is
that real
yeah you got to post that again before
this goes up because i think that was in
a story or you were just
posting you're posting the malibu
artists
at the malibu artist carlos g and his
his his um
yeah his p his post i shared that story
so i will post properly
cool um all right well let's take a
quick break
and we'll be right back with you
should know
sorry to interrupt the flow we'll be
right back with more awesome but
i want to snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of
nutrition the thing is most people i
know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to
incorporate more whole plants more
fruits vegetables
seeds beans and legumes into their daily
routine
sadly however without the kitchen tools
and support
very few end up sticking with it so
because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly and
because i want everybody to experience
some version of what i've experienced we
decided to tackle
and solve this very common problem the
solution we've devised i'm proud to say
is the plant power meal planner our
affordable
all-in-one digital platform that sets
you up for
nutrition excellence by providing access
to thousands of highly customizable
super delicious and easy to prepare
plant-based recipes
everything integrates with automatic
grocery delivery and you get access to
our
amazing team of nutrition coaches seven
days a week
and many other features to learn more
and to sign up
visit meals.richroll.com and right now
for a limited time we're offering ten
dollars off an annual membership
when you use the promo code rr health at
checkout this
is life-changing stuff people for just a
dollar seventy a week literally the
price of a cup of coffee
again that's meals.richroll.com promo
code
rrhealth for ten dollars off an annual
membership
all right let's get back to the show
the big story today we're going to talk
about the olympics
yeah it's on everybody's mind and we're
going to attack it from
the perspective of mental health and
we're joking
on the break adam said i want what you
want rich and i said
you have a boundary problem what's a
mental health issue
you can't you can't yeah so am i i
understand that
yes uh but ultimately that's a path
towards
unhappiness and misery maybe if you you
think you're being
what you do is you delude yourself into
thinking you're such a good dude like
i'm such a good guy because
i don't really care what i want i just
want everyone else to be happy
when you sublimate your needs or your
wants or you're
repressing them then ultimately you're
just you know kind of
creating a situation where you're going
to develop some resentments
got it i don't fully sublimate i don't
want to i don't want to paint the
picture that i don't but you are very
easygoing
yes and when i can i like to not think
like for me we're going to get into the
mental health story we should probably
set the table but we all know what we're
going to talk about uh
for me though what i was trying to say
was um
i don't overly analyze my emotions i try
not to so i'm more on the stoicist side
of things when you come to that like to
me like it doesn't help my process
to dive deep into my own emotions
because i actually think emotions are
often liars
now that's not now we're going to get
into the simone biles topic you know
obviously
uh winner of 30 combined olympic and
world championships medals best
uh gymnast of all time sure if it's not
her it's nadia so it's one or two
right it's probably her and um
she was in the final the team was in the
finals
and she had a bad vault and then she
left the competition
and and because it's so rare to see an
all-time great
step back from a competition in the
finals with a gold medal on the line
it it inspired a whole wave of
of analysis right and um
one of those the what she was saying is
that it wasn't
right for her mental health to continue
that was the initial statement
and you know she had to protect herself
and she
you know uh step back and let one of the
other
girls step in and they got a silver
medal which is you know still victoria's
outcome
um but because because it's so rare to
see it because we are all
conditioned for the stoicist idea of
champions
originally there was this big outcry of
you know i've never seen someone quit
on that stage blah blah blah and then
there was the
backlash to that no she's doing the
right thing she's she's taking a claim
for mental health
um and so became this kind of weirdly
unmoderated debate and the subject of
many a think piece
um and so where did you where were you
when all this was going on what were you
thinking about all this yeah it's
interesting
and and what's also fascinating about it
is that it became a partisan issue
yeah like everything else it became
politicized and your perspective
on what you know simone biles decided to
do
uh your perspective on that had to
reflect your political ideology
it didn't seem to a lot you know like me
personally
when i first saw it the first thing i
thought is i've never seen an all-time
great do that
so then i started thinking because i'm a
skeptical journalist so i started
thinking
was she going to lose anyway and she
didn't want to lose this is a way to
lose that without losing that's where i
first went
this is not a judgment on her this is
just where my thought process was
and then i thought um so i thought that
then i thought
i do like it when you know i did feel
like
she has a team it's not just an
individual thing that she's stepping
back from that's one thing
she does have a team that's relying on
her she's the leader of the team
so i did fall into that category even
though politically
it doesn't seem like that should be the
place that i line up that was the first
place
i did go to before kind of taking a step
back
and letting it settle and what kind of
convinced me
to think of it differently was when it
came she posted that she actually has
what they call the twisties i guess in
gymnastics
uh had the yips she couldn't land yeah
if you can't land you can't so
yeah the the way she described it is you
lose your
sense of like space and time so you're
in the middle of like a vault and you're
in the middle of the air and you don't
know which way is up and which way is
down yeah and this got played out in
those
early i think was it a vault or there
was some attempt where
um she intended to do i don't know what
it was like a two and a half two and a
half twists or whatever and only did one
or one and a half and landed
kind of off kilter that was clear
indication like
there was something going on here and
and i agree i think
that original kind of knee-jerk
sentiment is sort of a boomer adjacent
sentiment like us being older right like
what do you mean
you're gonna not you're gonna opt out
right right the very definition of a
champion is the person who
perseveres who demonstrates the grit and
when their back is against the wall and
everything's stacked against them
they they move forward nonetheless and
either prevail or don't
yeah that's the conventional wisdom here
and i think what what
complicates the simone biles situation
is a couple things first of all when
you're dealing with gymnastics you're
dealing with
um very dire physical consequences if
things go wrong
it's not just hey you know i'm not going
to run this race because i'm not feeling
it it's like if i
land wrong i could land on my neck i
could paralyze myself
and i think second to that there is
um there is truth in that
she was opting out for the best interest
of the team because if she wasn't going
to be able to
perform to her abilities then is that
really in the interest
of the team's quest to win a team medal
right
yeah would would that would that be
better filled by somebody else
so there was a self-sacrifice aspect to
it and i think
look you know greatest of all time
30 combined olympic and world you know
world championship medals
this is not somebody this is not like uh
a wilting flower
like this is somebody who has a champion
mindset who knows themselves as well as
anybody the level of like
self-integration that you would have to
have to perform
you know these routines that she does
it's just it's mind-blowing so this is
not somebody
who is scared of you know obstacles or
difficulties
so when this person says look i need a
break
it's not like there's a history of
simone saying that
right this is new so we should take it
seriously it should be a benefit
who do you think wanted to win the gold
medal more than her
nobody tucker chris jason
come on dude like yeah all the peoples
who had the hot take of
your your you know your your wimping out
are all
couch potatoes yes nobody who's well
versed
in elite performance had that
perspective
everybody from from
um michael gervais to
you know i i found a couple links like
david epstein who's been on the show
wrote in his range report
a whole thing about this brad stollberg
wrote an article for outside lindsey
kraus
wrote a couple opinion pieces one of
which quotes steve magnus
who's brad stohlberg's writing partner
who's also been on all these people been
on the pot they all kind of have the
same perspective which is like
look this is it gets confusing because
because the the celebration of what she
did
i think should be about the fact that
an athlete is taking greater control of
their life
and not allowing their decisions to be
dictated by
teams or organizations rather than
we're celebrating the fact that she's
opting out so
because it politicized and we can get
into that in a little bit because i have
a ted talk i'd like to unleash upon you
um but uh the
because of that the way it played out
there was this whole uh
set that wanted to make her a hero out
of it and
and which lionization yeah doing the the
of like
of like doing the the taking the the
quote-unquote easy way out the backlash
of the backlash
the thing that just begun had become
become she's a hero because she
uh opted out right quit however you want
to say it
because she's that is a weird thing for
for 50 something year old guys like
that's a narrative i'm not used to
it's it's first of all it's ridiculous
it's like this was a personal choice she
made
because she had her own calculus and
part of that calculus has to be
the fact that the us gymnastics has been
a corrupt organization that
that included uh uh
child like convicted molesters she was
abused by
by uh larry nassar the doctor she's one
of the survivors
there were you know what dozens of girls
that were um
that were abused by this man who's now
in prison
and there and you know the day that she
stepped back
from uh doing that routine on
the that day five years earlier she
actually went to indianapolis for an
event to benefit us gymnastics and the
guy that was showing around indianapolis
uh according to this report in
washington post by sally jenkins great
analysis which really changed started to
change the way i looked at this
to me it's it's the one story that felt
like it had true insight into
into some of the backstory of what was
going on in that
that person knew about nassar and
the gymnastics organization knew about
nassar
but didn't tell the gymnasts about
nassar and in fact let them let that
still continue and so
uh that happened five years to the day
and
you know one of the reasons she came
back she said this to an nbc reporter
uh hoda i forget i can't uh hoda all you
need
no code on today's show um she
uh said that you know if there weren't a
remaining survivor in the sport they
would have brushed everything aside and
probably
had these same athletes still training
at the crowley ranch
in texas um you know she came back at 24
which is an advanced age in gymnastics
as we all know
and she did that as to to help change
the sport
yeah and so to when you put all of that
in
into the pot and you stir it up um you
understand these demons are real
it's it like that had to be part of the
thing like should i sacrifice myself
right now
like for who and that had to be part of
it and that that doesn't necessarily
make it eat
make it open and shut case because as of
this taping
she is going to compete on the balance
beam she's going back out for one last
uh routine so she is going to do that in
an individual balance beam
but it had to be part of the situation
that led to
this twisties yeah july 27
being this day you know in 2015 as you
mentioned
that was the day two years ago yes yes
six years ago she was at usag
headquarters in indianapolis for a bunch
of promotional appearances
um and being accompanied uh by
you know this guy who was well aware of
what was going on
and was working with an fbi agent to
like sweep it under the rug right
promise that that fbi agent would get
some job with
the ioc or something like that i mean
this washington post article is pretty
incredible yeah it's incredible stuff
we'll link that up
um in the show notes but yeah it
provides a much
greater more in-depth context for what's
actually going on and when you think
about simone's career
now being an elder statesman which is
hard to believe because she's so young
and the care that she you know
undertakes to like
mentor all of these younger athletes
particularly um
you know athletes of color yeah uh which
is so important to her
compounded by this idea of being an
elder statesman who
links the legacy of nassar to the
current state of affairs like that's a
that's a lot to shoulder
yeah and twisty's it's not her first
time
no when was it there was some other
incident a couple years ago where she
had twisties it took her a couple weeks
to get over it so
and twisty it's like this one loses
track of your body position i guess
yeah yeah i guess i mean i'd never heard
of it before no
um but when you really evaluate it
you know and contextualize the whole
thing it's like she made the right
decision
for herself and for the team and it's
ballsy as
that she would make that decision given
a great awareness and understanding of
the consequences knowing it's going to
be this big controversial thing
knowing that it's going to cause a media
cycle and a media frenzy
but i think it takes a lot of gumption
and guts
to know what's best for you make that
decision
irrespective of what the reaction is
going to be and do it
for the interest of the long term
as opposed to the short term gains that
you might have reaped by
making a different decision right there
are all these case studies of other
gymnasts over the years who were pushed
push push pushed and were
competing with stress fractures and
broken feet and all kinds of stuff
and get the gold and then you never see
them again yeah so what are we really
talking about what's more important here
like getting the gold medal at this
olympiad or
you know simone being able to compete
for another four years
and be healthy and more importantly
who gets to make this decision
historically it's the teams or it's
the ioc or it's the usoc
and here we have simone standing on the
shoulders of naomi osaka and what she
did you know last month or whenever it
was to say
like i don't have to be a pawn i'm not
you know
a you know a pony here to dance for you
when you wish like i have sovereignty
over myself and my career and
i'm going to put my foot down and say
i'm not competing it's not right for me
and they should have the right to make
that decision
and we should respect and support that
it's true
i i separate i know everyone wants to to
to bunch
simone and naomi together as like
there is a qualitative difference versus
competing
yeah yeah one is doing press one
literally can't land in her sport one
it's not like naomi all of a sudden
can't make a serve but what unites them
is this idea of the athlete taking
control you know and doing it in the
face of all these other pressures like
as a young nobody like how dare you
judge
simone you don't know what's going on in
her head you can't imagine
the pressure that she's shouldering or
her interior experience
of being in tokyo and everything that's
going on around her with
the whole world focused on her that's
right i think
brad the brad stillberg article for
outside to me also was another one to
to really highlight um you know the
david i've seen one's great too
it talks about a a gold medalist in the
bobsled who
had then had to deal with figuring out
what what you know how to
what's my next act who am i now which
simone referenced you know after this
mental health
yeah and it all goes to like this is a
conversation sorry i didn't mean to
speak
words but this is a conversation that
we've been having on the show for a long
time that started with the weight of
gold in the michael phelps documentary
and this
growing awareness around the reality
of you know the mental interior
experience of the
elite athlete and kind of pulling covers
on that and helping people to understand
that these are human beings
and berkeley i mean the first probably
the first person on your podcast that
brought this particular conversation up
right i mean
yeah i mean i've had and we've had you
know alexi pappas has talked about we've
got tons of people
talking about this and so then uh but
brad's
article uh talks about this concept of
heroic individualism which is
you know that's why we worship athletes
and he's like his his point was that
there's a there's an innate problem with
worshiping the athlete and that is that
you're buying into heroic individualism
which is a game of one-upmanship against
yourself and others
and everyone has that in in western
societies his argument um it's it's it's
basically
baked into western society i know as a
writer i feel it you know i feel
that for real i feel in myself when i'm
working on something i feel it
uh in competition even with friends and
you know i feel it and that that's
i don't feel good about it like it's not
a positive experience
and you you feel like you feel it you
don't want to really buy into it but
it's there
um and so his point was you know she
made the right choice but sometimes the
right choice
would be to persevere through it so yeah
his is a much more nuanced
situation and he looks at kind of the
the the science on
on depression and and these mental
health issues he's his is not
the you know she's a she's a hero for
not doing it or she's a quitter she's
he's not in that camp at all
yeah yeah it's it's the difference
between it's like if you're
used to use running as an example it's
the difference between
my legs are really heavy and super tired
today and i don't feel like running
versus
there's a sharp pain in my knee like
what is a
what is a good pain and what is a bad
pain right what is
what is something to pay attention to
that's gonna
you know that wherein the right thing to
do is to stop and go no further versus
when is this just you know a difficulty
that could be overcome
through tenacity grit perseverance but
that's hard to know when it's a splinter
in your mind
sure yeah yeah but when you're an
athlete at that level you know the
difference
right trust me right you know it's not
like oh she's weak of will
like no there's just i just don't i
don't buy into that but i
the point is well taken like i get that
yeah no but she but i think the fact
that people just
jumped to this idea that she was being
you know
fearful or lazy i think is absurd
yeah like well i jumped to that
conclusion that she
was more like not used to losing and
therefore wanted to lose on her terms
and trying to control it that's where
like
here's a convenient way to not lose
right you just stopped out right so i
actually did
think that until i i didn't know about
the because she she didn't tell
everybody
she showed on her own stories her
attempting to land on the pillow
parallel bars and she was like the press
release was very brief it was like
she's she's um pulling out it's not due
to a physical injury
so i was like well then what is it and
that also makes you wonder who put that
out
who in that organization put that out
and why'd they put it out that way and
like like
could they have taken care of her a bit
more in that statement or that come from
her camp like all these things you you
wonder after you're reading that sally
jenkins story
yeah but to me like the biggest reveal
of all this is not necessarily her
mental state and what she's got to do
for herself because i think
when it comes down to it you're 100
right um
especially simone biles deserves the
benefit of the doubt especially an
all-time great if you're going to
worship athletes
then you have to give an all-time great
the benefit of the doubt and like if
that's what this person needs then
that's what that person needs
does that make her a hero not
necessarily but it makes her
human and so that's the point and that's
the tension right
like we don't want our our heroes to be
human right and this is a conversation
about
recognizing the inherent humanity in the
elite athlete
but also the olympics is there is
something to be
gained from and something to be said for
like holding people up a little bit
higher
as benchmarks to you know kind of drive
our own aspirations like i want heroes
yeah right
so that that heroes aren't cut out
characters like i have to appreciate
that they're actually human and they're
flawed
but i think we all benefit when we
celebrate people who do amazing things
i agree and that's part of what makes
your pro your podcast such
such a must listen is because you're
bringing in unknown heroes a lot or
maybe sometimes it is a known hero or
even just you know but
but to if you if you let one of those
heroes talk for two hours you're gonna
understand and appreciate the the
humanity
exactly they will probably tell you what
their weaknesses are or
you know their insecurities or what
happens and they'll make it seem
possible for you to be your own hero
which is the whole point right like by
the end
yeah but the idea was simone that
because she's this great champion
she is disempowered from making those
kinds of decisions for herself is wrong
like
you can't you can't opt out you're our
hero you're the you're the world
champion you're not supposed to do this
so i
i am projecting on to you a set of rules
that you must adhere to
in order to remain the hero in my mind
yeah and that's up
it is up and the other up
thing
is that here we are human beings social
creatures who have become social media
creatures right and that's what we're
talking about in the bo burnham
you know backlash to the backlash to the
backlash to the thing that's just begun
it's like six six media cycles within
the first five hours of the story
and it's like and until we actually
heard about the twisties a couple days
later when she posted it nobody actually
knew why she quit
yeah like no one knew like on the but
that doesn't stop everybody from having
their take or opinion or pierce morgan
from getting up and bloviating
and then discord feeds discord because
yes piers morgan and people on the right
had that take but on the left we do it
too i mean the left
rails against criminal justice system
and harsh sentences unless it's the cop
that murdered george floyd
the right loves cops wants to make love
to the constitution
unless we're talking about the 2020
election and insurrectionists on january
6th i mean
exactly it's everything it's just what's
politically expedient
yeah the narrative bends to bends to the
you know
the political ambition exactly and it
you know personal freedom for trans
people
is good personal freedom for
anti-masters not good or vice versa you
know it's like it's like
it's one side stakes out of position the
other screams and yells
and on the left you better scream and
well yelled exactly the right way
because if you don't
if you're just a little bit out of step
you're going to get you're going to be
torched and and we need a new culture
you know we need
not only do we not want to buy into
heroic individualism we need to replace
this with we over me
and if that starts with conversations uh
you know the favor my favorite moment of
the olympics so far are the two high
jumpers from qatar in italy
who were who had both tied and they were
given an opportunity do you want to do a
jump off
and one of you will be the true olympic
champion or do you want to share a gold
medal
and they they shared the gold medal they
hugged and kissed and it was beautiful
and it's like it's like people love that
and that's great and that makes me feel
good too
but also back to the stoic kind of
response like
if you are the gladiator do you do you
accept that
you say no we will we will fight to the
death to figure out who's better
i think russell crowe and gladiator
would have hugged damon hansu you think
so
yes maybe well their life was on the
line yeah the stakes were a little bit
higher
higher stakes um i did love that story
yeah um that was a good ted talk thank
you for my ted talks are you still
are there more points that need to be
made i'm sweating now
[Music]
i'm perspiring um listen man
it's i i think it's interesting that
this is
all coming up in the context of the
olympics because the olympics is
all about um well first of all
it's a globalist agenda oh right yeah
it's globalist by nature
it's it's the original globalization is
this not the one thing
where the world can stop and we can all
celebrate together and agree upon you
know
uh you know celebrating these amazing
human beings yeah apparently not i guess
apparently i guess
well i've never there hasn't been this
kind of discord
in olympic well i guess there always is
you're not that's not true
we had a boycott in 80. yep 84. so it's
always there's been a
a political aspect to all of this but i
feel like
now that's drilled down into it's it's
becoming even more because of the way
that the culture is
the difference is now it's not nations
that are having political infighting or
leaders from from oppressed groups
within a nation
it's it's individuals over it's
not like we're not even talking about
uh you know black power in 1968
at a time when there was incredible uh
oppression over and and they actually
risked their gold medals and gave up
their gold medals knowing
they would do it right we're not talking
about uh 1968.
we're talking about a woman a young
woman making a decision for herself
and then it becoming a political issue
like that was a political issue i know
this is like this is this isn't a
political issue i know it really isn't
and then it becomes one so it's like
it's backwards and uh
and you know i think it's upon uh coming
upon us to
want to like get getting back to your
comments like listeners
we gotta all be willing to have
conversations with people who disagree
with us
you know we have to because we're not
going to get anywhere
in solving big problems unless we're
willing to do that so it's interesting
the olympics
showed us another lesson there but yeah
that's
you know um simone manuel
the swimmer yeah um african-american
swimmer yeah
she her first name simone right yes
so everybody's confusing her with simone
biles
she had to tweet she had to tweet i
don't do gymnastics oh no
with like i did not know that i did not
know that and it has 42
000 likes that's that tweet
to clarify like no i'm not the gymnast
but i'm also like a kick-ass olympian
yeah
anyway crazy um i love the olympics i
would say that
i've i've watched less of this olympics
than any other olympics that
that have ever been since i've been
alive simply because i've been too busy
which is kind of a bummer yeah
we're also um i don't have cable tv
oh no so i got the peacock app for our
television so i could watch it thinking
i'd be able to just stream
what everybody else sees and it doesn't
work that way no nbc's i ended up like
experiencing the olympics through a
bunch of clips which was
not ideal oh really um but there are a
couple olympic
related things that i think we need to
talk about beyond simone
the first is what is with this roc
what's the roc russian olympia oh right
so basically russia
gets banned from the olympics right for
all of these doping
situations which emanate directly out of
brian fogle
and icarus and all the work that he's
done um but they find this loophole this
end run
around the spirit of the law which
allows all these russian athletes to
compete as long as they don't play the
anthem if they win like they can
they can even wear the colors right on
their sweatsuit so what's the difference
like who cares if they don't have the
flag
it's unbelievable it's roc it's the ioc
kind of capitulating i think yeah yeah
well capitulating to like what is that
what is the what is the real politic
there because the ioc
is just horrifically corrupt right
across the board in
so many ways and and and really truly
never has had
the athlete's best interest at heart it
really is a giant
power and money play like i don't even
think
i mean there really wasn't public
sentiment for the olympics to even occur
when they occurred because of japan's
contentious relationship with kovid
i mean i think most people would have
preferred the olympics get
pushed even further and the ioc because
of these broadcasting contracts and the
amount of money
that was at play there's no way they
weren't gonna
go forward also japan japan was out a
lot of money too if it didn't happen
right yeah and they they share that
yeah yeah i think yeah i think that's
right but ultimately it was the ioc's
call
they have like ultimate authority my
favorite part of the ioc
is that japan apparently has come out
that they lied about their july weather
and their bid and the ioc didn't like
examine
like just they just let's talk about
that because this is this is like uh
this is like that stanley kubrick movie
um
what's it called why am i uh you know
where the where t-boon pickens is riding
the atomic bomb out of the
oh um yes how do i learn to love the
bomb yes yes yes yes yes it's like
you think these people are adults and
are conducting themselves
with some uh you know level of
of of respectable decorum and you find
out like it's just a banana republic of
corrupt influences right
it's like it's like uh it is it's like
the big the the 1920s still
over there like like whoever they don't
read the report it's like
so explain to japan so apparently july
would
i i was happy we weren't even talking
about going to tokyo before
kovid and and and doing podcasts from
there when we first
that was going to be the first thing we
collaborated on we both wanted to go to
japan i'm happy that
the olympics are in japan i think it's
awesome but in 1968 when
mexico city got the olympics they moved
the olympics to early october if i
remember correctly late september early
october
because of weather and weather patterns
and health and and healthy air quality
and japan could have done that like it
could be in september when it's nice
there
um it's july it's late july when it's
like 95 degrees with 90 humidity
and in their bid in their bid they
characterize the weather as being
you know sort of balmy and not nearly as
as severe as it actually is in order to
secure
the contract right and because of the
way
television works and sports there's no
way that they would have pushed it to
the fall because it competes with
football
oh yeah back in 68 that wasn't as much
of an issue
yeah yeah so it's all about it's all
about tv but it's so funny then
then the ioc saying they never read the
report or they didn't they didn't really
look into it they didn't vet
it enough to realize like anybody who's
been to tokyo
in late july knows that it's unbearable
it's like would you do the summer
olympics in bushwick in august
no i wouldn't go to that
or maybe july they do the us open when
are they the u.s open
early september right yeah that's when
you should be doing
in the humid areas yeah um the olympics
um so there's that what are their big
athlete stories before we get into
i mean there's so many obviously you
know me being a swimmer swimming is what
i care about the most
and what i followed to the extent that i
was able to
you know follow much of it and even then
i you know it's this is the first
olympics where
i just really don't have personal
relationships with any of of the
athletes or the coaches
maybe one or two of the coaches i've met
in passing but typically like i have
friends or people that i know quite well
who
who are competing or or coaching this
year i really didn't have that
connection with so it made it
less you know like i'm so busy it just
was like oh who are these people i had
to like learn who everyone was
right with a few exceptions i mean i
think
listen this is the first one in in five
olympiads where there's no
lochte or phelps right i mean katie
ledecky is the you know legacy of that
era
but you're going into a new um
it's a new generation of swimmers and
that's
talk about a heavy burden to live up to
without those guys around how are you
gonna
basically put points up on the board
that are gonna make people interested in
what you're doing like
and with that you know caleb drussel
like showed up five golds crushed
basically had the ultimate olympics that
you could
you know ever expect from that guy and
it was just a pleasure watching him swim
and
set a couple he set a world record in
the hunter fly right and also on the
4x100 medley relay so that was cool
and maybe for crying on the air yeah he
did cry he was emotional
he's very handsome leslie jones has a
crush on him that's important who
doesn't how awesome is leslie jones in
her olympic commentary
she's hilarious i know she's so good and
they tried to
like mimic that with snoop dogg
and kevin hart which i felt was a little
canned compared to her just very
authentic she's like eating snacks
like watching television yeah yeah yeah
it's the best yeah if you're not on to
leslie jones
and her olympic commentary you got to
follow up just go to her twitter right
amazing yeah yeah
um so yeah i mean caleb dressler was
amazing uh and
you know it's interesting watching katie
ledecky like i don't want to belabor all
of this there's other places where you
can get a lot of olympic feedback but
you know i think that back to this issue
of mental health and the olympics
we can't discount the fact that all of
these athletes had to weather a coveted
year where their training was turned
upside down where
you know the predictability of whether
they would be competing or not was very
much in question like
incredibly difficult
when you understand that at that level
to be
you know to compete at the highest level
to be that elite
you really have to know like here's when
i'm competing here's how i'm organizing
my schedule to be ready by that time and
when all those dates are in flux
and at least i know in swimming like
pools aren't open then they're open but
then
it's like there's a lot of question
marks and i think katie being closer to
you know a later phase of her career um
you know i i think it took a toll on her
performance i think if the olympics had
if there had been no coronavirus and the
olympics occurred last summer
i think she would have swept her events
and would have been unchallenged
um you know she did get better as it
went along right like
there was that when they got the uh
silver in the relay which one was that
the uh um
it was the four by two hundred yeah was
it four by two hundred
so i think so i don't think i watched
that race and they became in silver so i
think she got the silver
she got two silvers and two golds right
mm-hmm
and that in that race they were far
behind like they like when she got into
the pool
she was over a body length behind i
thought she was like 10 feet maybe two
body lengths behind yeah
and to watch her almost reel them all in
to me that was one of the coolest swims
i saw this entire olympics
i was like you at the beginning the
first four or five days
i wasn't paying any attention you know
first of all it's like
by the time you turn on the prime time
uh
olympics you kind of like you
everything's already happened and you
know unless you seal yourself off from
your phone you're going to know a lot of
the results
um in the past it's been easier for me
to manage that like the last two
london and it's a little bit less of a
time zone problem it's still there but
you can manage it yeah
um in this case i was like the first
four or five days i wasn't paying any
attention
but i've slowly been wooed back in
even with no crowds it is sad watching
the track especially with pool you don't
see the crowds that much because you're
focused on the pool but the camera angle
on the track
it's all the empty seats it is sad um
it's not it's not the way it's supposed
to be but i'm seeing katie ledecky
do that swim and then afterwards when
they were asking her if
is this your last i think that was her
last event is this your last swim
and she's like i'm not retiring no she's
coming back she's like i'll be back in
four more years yeah which i loved and i
thought she
performed great like again it goes back
to the you know this idea
is is anything but gold a failure and
you know maybe she has a great attitude
too
always a smile on her face always a hug
always a nice positive thing to say
you know really just acquits herself
with such
grace what a spectacular athlete i know
yeah a little
uh curious aside so she's
from my club team in dc she grew up in
dc okay and she
trained when she was in high school at
the
shitty pool at georgetown prep which
high school is private high school where
our club team rents the pool for full
time and that's where i trained all
through
high school twice a day and i think they
renovated it in the years because
obviously i'm like twice her age or
whatever you guys both peed in the same
pool
we did we both be yes separated by
decade probably
i think the pool was renovated since i
was there but this pool
was just a toxic hazard i mean it was
it would drip like black tar from the
ceiling
into it and we would be like if we get
cancer it's probably because we're
drinking whatever's
dripping out of the ceiling into the
water and you would go in there in the
morning it would just be this cloud of
of chlorine vapor you know and
and because we shared it it was it was
belong to this
high school we couldn't use the locker
rooms half the time because their
students were we would like sometimes we
could use the football locker rooms and
go in there it's all muddy
but for afternoon workout we would have
to change in the pump room
like you couldn't even get and it was
just dirty and disgusting
but kind of awesome too that like you
cut like you don't want the super nice
pool
when you're grinding right you know it's
like the original rocky like you want
you want to like you want to be in the
in the you know the grimy
gritty you know situation so that when
you when you when you finally qualify
for that fancy meet you go to
indianapolis and you see that incredible
natatorium you're like wow
right yeah you don't want to train in
that fancy place you're like you're like
you guys are like the hickory like in
hoosiers you're like the team hickory
the word they makes me very
uncomfortable like i should not like i'm
just saying i
swam in the same pools or like i don't
know good for katie
she's the all-time goat unbelievable
athlete
shout out gw i know
nice how about emma mckeon australian uh
yeah winningest
female australian swimmer ever yeah i
think yep
incredible i think the winniest
winningest swimmer i mean
seven medals four gold yeah yeah yeah
yeah so the most
very few have have gotten that i think
well caleb got five gold
and the only other swimmers to do that
are phelps and
mark spitz and biandi biandi in 88 right
in seoul
and then there's a speed skater eric
heights oh eric hyden yeah my all time i
got it my all-time hero
yeah that guy um also cool to see
some new faces we got bobby fink in the
distance races which
he's a guy he's sort of the converse of
katie like he was somebody no one had
really
knew anything about who really benefited
from the extra year to like hone his
strength and
endurance and he goes from like unknown
to absolute legend being the first
american in 37 years to win the 1500
and then also wins the 800 which is cool
um
very cool a little sort of side anecdote
with that typically it's always been the
1500 meters for the men and the 800
meters for the women
there has never been until this olympiad
of 1500 meters for the women because
historically it was considered too
difficult for women
women can't swim that far can't swim
that far and the fact that it took until
2021 to rectify that is out of control
strange thing to think when a woman was
one of the first people to swim across
the english channel
anyway um the ioc has been legendary for
many many years
the uh the last person yeah yeah i know
so ahead of the curve yeah they've
always read read things so well
um i do want to spend a couple of
minutes talking about this guy michael
andrew oh let's talk about him
to me kind of the most interesting
curious
swimmer on the us olympic team this is a
guy who
i mean i've been aware of this guy
forever because
even though he's how old is he now he's
like 22 or he's pretty young dude
he's young but this is a kid who his
entire life
has been um expected to
inherit the phelps legacy because
when he was a kid he broke over a
hundred national age group records
like he completely rewrote all the
national age group records
as he grew up like basically breaking
all of them
so more than any other swimmer ever has
more than
michael phelps so the obvious
expectation is like this guy's the
second coming right he's going to come
in and he's going to crush
um and he failed to make the olympic
team in rio i think he was like 17 at
the time so that makes him
i don't know 23 or so 22 now
yeah um and and what's so he makes the
team this year
and um ends up on the
4x100 medley relay setting a world
record so he gets a gold medal
yeah he doesn't meddle in any in the
individual event
and what makes him so curious is the
fact that this guy has a very
unique original way of training that
contravenes all conventional wisdom so
most swimmers
swim twice a day they're putting in
anywhere between 12 and
20 000 meters a day a lot of volume
plus dry lands and you know weight room
and all kinds of other stuff
he uh is coached really he's like
homeschooled
coached by his dad managed by his mom
grew up in kansas swimming in a pool in
his backyard like didn't do the club
thing where you go and swim with other
people like just basically
was in the backyard with his dad right
this single lane pool
that he trained in now they live in
encinitas i think in in san diego
um but he's remained kind of
homeschooled and under his
parents control control is probably
the wrong word but i mean sort of
influence yeah um
and his dad uh in conjunction with
another
coach have developed this thing called
usrpt
which stands for um ultra
short race pace training
so whereas most swimmers are training 12
to 20 000 yards or meters a day
he's swimming like 3 000 a day which is
nothing but all of the training is at
race
pace so everything is like lung busting
all-out efforts approximate your
your race to the extent possible make
the most of that
compressed period of time and call it a
day
the idea being that most swimmers are
putting in all these junk miles they're
just swimming back and forth in the pool
it's not really doing anything for them
which is you know very controversial
and it's interesting to think about
because on the one hand look this guy
made the olympic team he was
won a gold medal in the four by 100
melee relay he got fourth in the 100
breaststroke he's still early in his
career
uh so he's had tremendous success but
basically when i look at this
particularly from an endurance
athlete's perspective i see a guy who
actually i think and i'm not one to
judge him i don't know him but
it would appear to me based upon his
race performances that he would benefit
by increasing his volume a little bit
because if he watches 200 im
the guy is like way ahead of world
record pace at the 100
at the 150 he's leading and then he goes
30 plus for the free leg like he
absolutely falls apart like in just an
epic crash and ends up
getting reeled in yeah he got i mean he
gets you i mean
at the olympics you rarely see somebody
die like that right
and i see somebody who has no aerobic
base
who can't sustain an effort over 200
meters
and michael phelps has commented on this
he basically said if you want to do well
at the 200 meters
200 im you got to train the 400. right i
don't think michael he's a sprinter
the 200 is a stretch for this guy i'm
sure he you know would prefer to just do
hundred meter races
but if you're going to compete at the
highest level in the 200 like you gotta
it's
even though it's a two minute race on
some level
in the context of swimming there is an
endurance component to that and if you
want to tap into a
uh a greater gear and bring it home
there's just no um there's no getting
around the fact that you got to put in
some volume training to do
that that you had said before that they
stopped doing those 10 to 12 000
yard workout days well it is much more i
think overall
it is more race specific okay so there
is a lot more
quality oriented training that goes in
and i've just noticed that from
workouts that i've dropped in on where
there are some olympians or like some
you know guys that are in their 20s who
are training at a high level like i've
noticed
it's a lot different but still they're
they're
going to the pool they're training you
know four hours a day
so it's still large about ten thousand
three thousand meters you can get done
in 45 minutes to an hour right that's
all the training you're doing in the
pool
a day and not doing weights either super
interesting
and i think look he's not doing weights
i would say my era was too much volume
right given that you 100 butterfly 49 47
seconds
you're gonna swim five hours a day right
like you know do you really need that
much endurance for that
200 butterfly maybe a little bit more
but still i was over trained completely
yeah so i think the pivot to being
quality oriented
is appropriate but i still think
that you need that volume piece if you
want to be
able to be dexterous and capable
you know in events from the 100 to the
200. and if you look at
runners or you look at cyclists like
every elite
competitor is creating an aerobic base
and then building upon that
and the fact that he shook that it's
it's it's interesting to look at it but
i don't know that i you know i really
think that he would have benefited
particularly in the 200 im
had he approached his training a little
bit differently phelps kind of called
uh that you know it would be interesting
to see if he can sustain it
you know right on his broadcast michael
phelps has been very good on tv
incredibly good yeah i mean he crushed
it he's been doing great and
his hair looks fabulous his beard is
less fabulous
there's a lot of fans for his beard his
hair looks really good
i would kill for his hair so yes but i
wouldn't but you know what we should
bring our beards back in honor of phelps
he's been
amazing we'll see yeah we'll see but
yeah i mean he
he's got a big career in broadcasting he
couldn't have been better he was
fantastic
but i still much love for my boy rowdy
gaines
nobody gets more excited about these
races than rowdy the
nbc played like they had a camera on
rowdy yeah the rowdy cam
did you watch i tweeted it earlier today
like he's just losing his mind
during the rap it's a it's like a full
body performance
he's fabulous i know um so kudos to
rowdy gaines
uh kudos to flora duffy the bermudian
native who won the triathlon yeah that
was a cool story
um who else oh let's talk about this
ryan murphy thing
yeah that's what i was gonna say did you
see that like the after
uh rylev uh beat murphy
in uh the was it the 200 i think he beat
him in both both 100 and 200 yeah
so i think it was after the 200th though
that uh
murphy they got on a dice together and
murphy's said something
to the point of i wish i could know i
don't know
that this was a fair race basically i
don't know that rylov is clean
um because of the roc thing that you're
talking about
was there anything else that he knows
that we don't know though
that's the question so what have you
heard do you think do you think swimming
is clean
i'm not close enough to swimming anymore
to know for a fact or to have any kind
of educated opinion on that
but i would suspect that there's
probably some bad actors
you know i think when you're watching
the tour de france or you're watching
olympic track and field or you're
watching swimming
i think it's naive to to assume or
presuppose that it's
100 clean because there's always going
to be people who are trying to get
around that kind of stuff so
but i don't know to what extent you know
there's any kind of doping going on i
have no idea
so i just i just don't have an informed
opinion on it
and what would it be listen
you know and i don't know ryan murphy
either but for him to say in a press
conference that he
he doesn't really accuse rylov but he
kind of in an
in a backhanded way he's kind of
accusing him he does accuse him so it
makes sense
but he does is that just because the ara
like the russians found an end run
to nonetheless show up at the olympics
under this
roc thing or is there something specific
to rylav
that he knows rylov was doing or he's
heard rumors
that we haven't heard about something
that was going on with him well i think
it makes me think there must be more to
this than just like i'm pissed that the
russians were
are here when they were actually banned
yeah there is something specific to ryla
rylov is the guy that beat him twice
yeah right so of course in his mind he's
like wait i could say
it's sour cream it's sour grapes or
maybe he's like you know this guy's been
getting away with this for a long
time i don't know
it's possible i mean the one thing i
look at when i think of performance
enhancing drugs i i think of body
changes and muscles and rylov was
surprisingly skinnier than almost
everybody up there and uh and murphy is
like chiseled from stone now
murphy has quite a physique but but the
thing is doping doesn't really work that
way
not blood doping right yeah blood doping
doesn't work that way i would be
surprised if it was blood doping where
you're
injecting yourself with other people's
blood but epo
you know basically these things allow
you to train
harder and longer so it you know it
creates a a more robust training cycle
so it's not necessarily like um
something that's going to make you huge
in in terms of it's not like steroids
where you're muscular you're trying to
improve your body's ability to
metabolize oxygen
for right you know energy i mean and and
some people are more ectomorphic than
other people right
so ryan murphy i think is just
genetically predisposed to look like
you know a bodybuilder comparatively but
just because the other guy rylov is
skinny and
felt and doesn't and has more of an
endomorphic
um disposition is not
a reason to think he must not be doping
no no right right
i mean murphy's a stud he you know who
knows what rylov is doing i
i'm not on the camp though just because
uh fogle's film is amazing
but i'm not here to think that every
russian athlete is doping i mean
it's it's a yeah i don't know i don't
know i don't know either who knows yeah
who knows you know i just i think that
that is you know that everyone has their
internal
i mean i don't think ever you can't you
can't make that judgment and um
i think there was some anger for losing
and it had to be something in there
maybe yeah who knows who knows um
who knows but that's what we're talking
about stuff we don't fully know about
yes we're just we're just spinning
opinions on stuff you know in a very
half-baked way here
no it's three-quarters baked um there is
one other thing that you wanted to
discuss that we should discuss and that
is the
new fitness fab oh right yeah yeah yeah
in uh tokyo this is wild yes um
should i go get them i'll go get them
yeah go get go grab those things so
basically
every olympiad there's some crazy you
know
technique or training philosophy that
emanates out of it that that becomes
like a story
in the previous olympics it was cupping
like you saw all the athletes walking
around with the
the kind of dark circles on their back
and on their shoulders
this year it's something called katsu
katsu katsu k-a-a-t-s-u
yes which is basically um
this uh what do you call it like a a
blood flow restrictor yep um
type thing like a bands that you put
around your extremities to restrict
blood flow
that when used in training stimulate
your your
hormonal system and your circulatory
system
to produce a result that mimics
training right so it's yes that's a
really bad way of just the idea is to
to make the circulatory system more
elastic so it's basically you're getting
you're increasing elasticity of your
capillaries
which allows by restricting blood flow
and then
letting it go so it's like it's like 30
seconds restricted
five seconds to let it flow and back and
forth what you're doing is
you're creating elasticity there which
triggers the hormonal system and a
lymphatic response
to get rid of um waste basically
uh metabolic waste lactic acid you can
flush that out
um it's essentially a tourniquet it's
basically a turn so
originally the but it doesn't completely
restrict the blood flow you're not
trying to cut it off completely
right so it is it is a tourniquet they
used to be just
bands that you could use and maybe train
that way
in reality the katsu these bands here
that we have
that are that now there's a a brand
called katsu training
um that stephen munatones is uh
involved with who is basically runs
wowza the open water swimming
association
is the number one chronicler of all
things open water swimming
i've known steve forever and i did not
know anything about this
so in 2001 he met the guy who was
using katsu just in tourniquet form just
in bands
manually with you know 20 people
one of them he actually doctor satu this
doctor
and steve i guess is fluent in japanese
yes apparently and so he went and met
with him in 2001 i guess it was
and at that time there was a thought
that
you know as you age you muscles atrophy
and bone density uh diminishes and
that's just the way it goes
and there's nothing you can do about it
weights help to some degree that's why
they ask older people to get into the
gym and do some weight resistance stuff
and machines
to make sure you don't lose bone density
he proved with these bands and his
techniques
in a 104 year old woman i believe it was
he built bone density and 104 year old
using blood flow restriction
and so uh you know steven got involved
with him
and they developed a way basically using
kind of a blood pressure cuff technology
with air
and pressure a way to make it automated
so that you can use it and
what stephen uh a lot of the reporting
there's been
futterman uh matt fighterman at the new
york times did a great story this is the
first story
podcast former podcast guest always
qualify
yes matt fudderman yes yeah he wrote
this cr who
who basically runs the sports desk does
he not what's his job specifically but
uh he he is an editor and now he's
mostly reporting these days
but um he wrote this great article for
the time yeah a hot fitness trend among
olympians blood flow restriction and he
talks all about this which is
i i just i don't know how i never heard
about this i started looking into it
ben greenfield actually did a whole
podcast episode
about this like a year ago and he had
steve
on as a guest so if you want to learn
more check that out
um but but so steve told me that it's
it's actually better for recovery and so
he sent them to me right before i did
the goggins you know 4x4 48
because he knew i had problems with my
feet and and so i used them then in
between and i
how did this not show up as a
show-and-tell earlier though i brought
him once
and then yes and then we forgot or i
forgot i forget what it was
um but so i use them before and after
but mostly after and he says that the
reason you do that is because it allows
so so people ice usually if after a run
if you have bad
joints the ice after playing basketball
yays ice has been this thing that
everybody tells you to do
um physical therapists tell you doctors
tell you
he's saying ice only what ice does is it
it it it sends the blood back and
it increases some sort of circulation or
restricts or increases circulation in
some places
and but he says it's very superficial
the blood will only flush out
very close to the skin and it'll it'll
stay in the area what this does is it
allows
actual blood flow to restrict and then
and then re flow again and that allows
you to really recycle the blood get that
metabolic waste out of there
and so basically what happened was in
2001 he met up with him he created this
thing
and and still it was used to general
public but gradually steve
got more and more athletes interested it
what turned the tide was he got the navy
seals interested
so navy seals started using it from
there some nfl players started using it
the first olympian to use it was carmelo
anthony the basketball player right
in 2016. he started to use it
um and that and it leaked out from there
and so now
it's basically every i mean every single
uh sport has someone all these
professional
sports franchises are are using this
martial artist there
he's like i don't know i was today years
old when i found out about this
it's the new thing and he's saying it
also helps with sleep
so what he told me today was uh that
you can um you can use
you can basically if you put it on right
before sleep or an hour before
it will uh around your arms it will
trigger a parasympathetic response in
your body and it will help you get
more into sleep instead of melatonin you
can use
katsu i've never tried it for sleep
right try it for sleep tonight
um but the other thing he said was that
it's in such demand
people are calling him from tokyo to get
this japanese-inspired product
shipped to him and they basically they
are
like they need to find product luckily
his main manufacturer in korea
was smart enough to stockpile uh
microchips
he saw kovit happen and he knew they're
gonna there's gonna be a run on
microchip somehow oh wow
like the one guy in the world that knew
so there's this in the futterman piece
yeah uh there's also this character dr
jim
stray gunderson yes who has become a big
advocate of this he's a
physician and a sports medicine
researcher who's worked with olympic
organizations in the us and in norway
and he was
the guy who pioneered the live high
train low approach which
which is this idea that um the best way
to take advantage of altitude training
is to
live at super high altitude and then
kind of go down the mountain and train
at sea level and then sleep you know
high and that's how you
get the boost of oxygen carrying red
blood cells etc
but apparently uh stray gundersen gets
excited about katsu trained with sato
over the last decade becomes this katsu
master and essentially is quoted in this
article as saying you can get the
benefits of swimming 10
000 yards by swimming maybe a thousand
which goes to the point
of michael michael andrew because
michael becomes this proponent of it
um in his you know unique training
um philosophy and practices
but andrew also what futterman says in
this article
is that um he started experimenting with
with bfr blood flow restriction five
years ago at the urging of chris morgan
a quote unquote veteran swim coach chris
is like an old friend of mine right
right right remember why
i shared about going to the monofin
world championships like he was on that
team that's how i got to know chris
chris has gone on to um coach uh
european national teams and then he was
an assistant coach at harvard like he's
a very
he has a lot of really cool training
philosophies and methodology is a good
dude
and maybe we can get chris to come on
and talk about katsu a little bit more
because it sounds like chris is sort of
at the
the bleeding edge of blood flow
restriction
i certainly want to know more about this
it sounds a little bit like a panacea to
me yeah
um but uh
can't uh you know get around the fact
that
that some of these athletes were were
using this uh in preparation for tokyo
he said it's been about wearing them on
your arms while you're swimming or while
you're in
the gym lifting weights so he was so
talking to monotonous on my drive here
actually
he kind of he didn't he didn't suggest
that uh funnerman got it wrong or
anybody got it wrong he thinks all these
athletes did their job well
but his perspective is that
recovery is the thing recovery is really
where it's gonna have the best effect
because you don't need to wear these
bands and swim like swimming is training
for swimming
not wearing my bands he's saying the
bands should be worn in between
so sprinters use it shikari who couldn't
you know because she got disqualified
after
smoking uh marijuana she uses them
um let me see that slide that over here
gatlin uses them the sprinter uh
but they they um you put you put like
so i put it around still but what is
this like you have to blow air into it
it connects with this guy so there's a
pump and then
part of it yeah it connects with this
thing
and then and it fills it with you cycle
it
and you hear that it fills it with air
yeah well you know what during the photo
session we'll
uh we'll put some katsu on yeah
i feel like an iv drug user
that's what it is it's like it's a legit
you know tourniquet right
all right yeah i don't know how this
works i'm definitely doing this wrong it
looks good on you
we need an expert on here no i'll show
you i'm still getting over the fact that
you've
you've had this for a while and i knew
nothing about it i'm getting over the
fact that all our shows
for a while and i could have broken the
story before futterman and i
missed my opportunity because i didn't
see it i did you did
um all right cool bad reporting bad so
anything else you want to say anything
else about the i mean you know look i
love the olympics we could talk about
this forever it is weird watching it
with no spectators and um
[Music]
uh you know it's just it's a strange
time but i'm glad that you know these
athletes are having this experience
it must be surreal for them to compete
without audiences
the whole thing is all very strange and
i just i love all things olympics i grew
up with that olympic dream myself
and i've always just it's always just
held a really special place in my heart
so
i'm a um i am a glorious kind of
like fan and optimist around all things
olympics
while also knowing the ioc and all these
organizations are completely messed up
i grew up knowing i had no chance at
ever being in the olympics
but uh i've always enjoyed watching well
you know what i i love the camaraderie i
love the different nations i love the
international
appeal the cultural exchange you know
in this it's so it really
inspires me to see the cultural exchange
to see the the countries coming together
um
and this year i've loved the hurdles out
of nowhere like yeah i i
freeze frame like when you see a couple
of them go over and then the ones
chasing
and then you know when they're the ones
behind are over and then i pause it to
see and everyone's off the ground all at
once and it's just like
pretty cool the photography um and
speaking of photography i just want to
give a shout out
uh to a photographer i've worked with
before
um donald morale i think i'm pronouncing
his name correctly
i've worked with him on a story for espn
he's a long time sports illustrated
photographer a great
prone paddler based out of san diego
area and he has
the best uh instagram feed from tokyo
he's shooting for nat geo and the stuff
he's putting out there
is just unparalleled so i want to link
to that yeah i'm looking at his
instagram right now it's pretty stunning
yeah donald donald morale m-i-r-a-l-l-e
however you pronounce that this picture
of caleb dressle with the traps
oh my god i mean he's got pictures of
the fencing that's incredible pictures
of cycling the underwater photos are
amazing so he
uh he explains in one of his posts he
was one of the innovators of
underwater swimming photos so he would
go down there and set camera traps
before they had the track down and now
there's a track
that everyone can have access to but um
he would go down there and set
trap it set camera traps with a couple
other guys that are innovating it back
you know you know i guess 20 years ago
and so he's uh
he's special that's cool yep how do you
feel about
surfing and skateboarding and all the
new stuff
i'll tell you this i love basketball
three on three basketball should not be
an olympic sport yeah
like i'd rather see foursquare or uh you
know like kickball uh dodgeball
i i'm not into this this x games meets
the olympics thing i've never really
been into it really
i like i think snowboarding is a great
olympic sport i'm not so sure about
skateboarding at bmx
i mean how can you differentiate then
how can you be okay with snowboarding
and not okay with skateboarding
you know i'm okay with surfing too to be
honest with you as an olympic sport
just changing your uh i don't know how
dare you change your mind in real time
adam i have an inner tucker carlson that
just gets after me constantly
yeah i don't know where you draw the
line with this obviously not everything
shooting is included in the election
well shooting has been in the olympics
forever i mean if you
i think to me the benchmark is always
like thinking about the original spirit
of the olympiad
yeah and what it was intended to be
which was what and i think you have to
respond to culture and when
like everything is fluid just like
language isn't fixed like these things
are always changing
i know but i'm a huge baseball fan and
none of the real professional baseball
players are playing so why is baseball
in the olympia i don't know it's weird
like that right and soccer the same way
with basketball you get the nba guys
right with baseball you don't
and i don't think the premier league
guys are playing in the soccer side i
don't think so i don't think they're
getting the premier like it's not the
world cup team that's over there it's
not the same
different players i don't not in every
case yeah yeah
it's weird how that works it is weird
roc
it's the rs can't get yeah the roc thing
you don't want that you want them really
properly like i'm such an old man that i
remember
the pain like i knew people who made the
80 team and how challenging
that was when they then when it was
boycotted and they couldn't go
well so now there's a boycott now
there's a boycott and they still go
it's not a boycott it's a ban i mean a
ban yeah yeah basically
but the point being if you're an athlete
you don't get to go
right yeah um but they get to go
do you watch the winter olympics the
same way you watch the summer
not as keenly me neither yeah but maybe
i i think i will this year
yeah they have there's more there's more
people dressed head to toe in lycra in
the winter olympics which i think is
interesting
our swimsuits are there the the there's
a lot of lycra in the summer olympics
there's not a great our swimsuits have
not been the most
i mean our costumes are not great no
liberia why does ralph lauren get
appointed to design the
us olympic team uniform every time
because we couldn't find levi strauss
are we all like is the is the u.s
olympic team all living in montauk
yeah i want i want a 75 year old man
designing my clothes we need some
freshness
breathe we need like we need to design
we're going down the tubes here let's
get to some listener questions
let's do it justin from minnesota
hey adam and rich this is justin from
minnesota so my question for you guys
is we often hear that you know living
examined life is important and doing the
work is
important as well but what is the work
what is doing
the work uh i'm struggling with this as
i try and find
a way to you know reflect more and
look at where i've been what i've done
and what i want to do
and i want to know what the work is and
what how where to begin
so that i can find a path forward and
feel
like i'm living a more purposeful life i
recently had
twins and it's been a seismic drift
in the way things go in life as you can
imagine and so i want to
do the work on myself to figure out how
i can be
a good father but also still achieve
the goals and dreams that i had free
fatherhood which is just
as i put it then put on hold for the
time being so
any advice on what uh to do for the work
to go
deep on oneself uh journaling etc
what to journal about all that kind of
good stuff i would greatly appreciate it
thanks for everything you do love the
podcast love you guys
talk to you later how van neistat is
that question it's pretty
essential i love it it's essentialist
it's a great
this might be the best question ever
asked what is doing the work
i love it because you hear it all the
time you hear well he did the work
well look at him he did the work or that
guy's doing the work he's able to do
this because he put the work in
and i found myself asking what is this
work
that everyone is doing i don't
understand right and you feel like adult
like you don't want to ask because you
don't want to look stupid
right but no one is very detailed ever
or specific about what
it is that that person actually did
so let's try to answer that um
i think there's no right or wrong answer
there is no one way there is no one work
i think the work is going to be
different for every person depending
upon your circumstances
and um you know what it is that you're
you're
you're trying to unlock or reckon with
in your
past or in your presence but i think
overall the basic idea around the work
quote unquote the work is engaging in
some form of
inward journey some form of some
practice
of self-examination that's
motivated by a genuine
intent to better understand yourself
objectively honestly so that you can
have a greater sense of awareness around
not just what you're doing but why
you're doing the things that you're
doing
why you tell the stories that you
continue to tell yourself
why you continue to repeat a certain
behavior pattern even though you know
it's moving you in the wrong direction
and i think the process of doing that
the specific
means by which you kind of unearth your
unconscious mind or
confront your biases or get objectively
honest with
your past is through a variety
of different modalities it can be seeing
a therapist
it could be seeing it could be
psychoanalysis or it could be
group therapy with a bunch of guys it
could be a 12-step program it could be
journaling there was a specific question
that justin asked about german what kind
of journaling well
you know i think the kind of journaling
that you're more likely to do
like it doesn't have to be any one way
you could do
morning pages out of the artist's way
where it's literally mumbo jumbo just to
kind of
um you know clear the cobwebs in your
mind
or it could be very intentional like
trying to remember things that happened
to you in the past so that you can make
sense of them
there is no right or wrong way the only
the only the only kind of uh
objective correctness in all of it is
that you are
trying like that you are moving inward
in some way that feels uh appropriate
for you
to make sense of your interior life
it could be reading books it could be
having an accountability partner it
could mean
having a mentor who can reflect back to
you uh
you know the uncomfortable truth of your
behavior it can be
uh it can involve creating a gratitude
list or any number of self-care
practices so i don't know how helpful
that is i don't i certainly don't want
to leave justin more confused
right but i think it it just means
commitment to one thing or
a number of things that are putting you
into greater
contact with and understanding of what
makes you tick
and why so that you can rewire
whatever you know errant
pathways are you know continuing to lead
you into directions you don't want to go
and finding healthier outlets for
your energy that will set your life on a
better trajectory
what do you think i'm trying to figure
out where his head space is
in terms of asking this question like um
to find a path forward and feel like
he's living a more purposeful life so
does that mean
he's doing work or doing a job that he
he's not feeling connected to is he not
feeling fully connected to
the purpose in his life because i mean i
think there's nothing more purpose than
two babies that showed up on your
doorstep
well that's the immediate and he has to
be addressed i think he wants to connect
something else
to that because they do feed each other
right if you feel fulfilled in one
aspect of your life it can make you feel
fulfilled on the other but my sense is
that
the twins thing is so overwhelming that
there's this lurking fear that he's
never going to be able to
uh you know execute on his other goals
and you don't want to become the person
that just like
is you know doing a job just because you
know just to pay bills
because bills need to be paid because
they do especially now
but um so i guess that's where my head
goes i think you're right in terms of
like just
the whole idea is just looking inward
maybe
that's the first step you know doing the
work can be a meditation practice it
could be 10 minutes every morning
sit down before you talk uh and and just
sit quietly for ten minutes it's hard to
do that when you're right so this guy's
got twins
yeah this is gonna be monopolizing you
know his time so
he's not gonna be able to say well i'm
gonna wake up and the first part of my
day is gonna be quiet like
clearly you're living your life when you
have young twins you're living your life
reactively
which is not great like i think it's
more about like how to
shift that valence from being reactive
to proactive
but understanding that when you have
twins it just is what it is man yeah and
it's not always going to be that way
and learning how to like flow with it
rather than resist it
because you know that resistance isn't
going to change your reality it's just
going to make you
more miserable because your life isn't
meeting some
you know fantastical expectation that
you've set for it
just being okay with what is and carving
out
whatever time you do have or those
moments in between
everything else that you're doing to you
know find
some kind of practice that will help
give you a little bit of peace clarity
and objectivity
i think accepting what is
that's a huge is like the first step
right like to me like you got to accept
where you are and and and who you are
first and that's always the first step
and so you know there's ways of doing it
quick you know anything like going to
therapy or going to a group therapy
or journaling all that stuff is time
intensive and of course
time is at a premium right now so
accepting self
um maybe maybe coming up with some sort
of
uh habit or or pattern that you can do
with the kids like get them into a dual
stroller and go for a run or something
like that for
even 15-20 minutes and just speak your
mind into a recorder
anything like that you can do at the
same time things like that just
just focusing the lens internally for
some
chunk of the day and doesn't have to be
a long part of your day
um is a good way to start you never know
and in those overwhelmed moments
i think having a a gratitude practice is
important just write down
five things you're grateful for to try
to remember
the big picture that's a great thing you
can do that every day
yeah what a blessing it is that you have
two healthy twins yeah
but that's a great question it is a good
question i hope we answered it
sufficiently i don't think we did but
we're going to move on now okay
we're going to do a less
well just some more just a different
type of question this is a different
kind of question isn't it
yeah jess from the open road hey guys um
my name is jeff
i am from illinois originally but i'm a
travel nurse
and so i actually was last travel
nursing in north carolina and then i'm
headed to maine next week
so i was curious as to
a couple things so top five bands from
each of you
and then one or the other top five
songs or top five albums
i would love to hear what you guys have
to say about that
i think that would be really interesting
to hear anyway um
thank you so much and take care i will
answer this question but
off the top of my head but i don't know
that i
i'm i'm glad that jess thinks this will
be interesting i don't know if anybody
else would think it was interesting that
depends what you said
you know i was born in 1966 i grew up in
the
you know 70s and 80s i think everybody
you know when you when you go through
those adolescent years those
early teen years i don't know 14 through
18 or 19 something gets imprinted on you
the music that you're listening
at that time becomes your favorite music
and it's very
that becomes like sort of anchored in
you
i don't think it changes much you know i
grew up
listening to you know i mean the big one
for me is rem
i loved rem that changed what i thought
music could be
i fell in love with that when i was in
college i listened to a lot of
english beat and joy division and and uh
you know kind of new a new new wave type
stuff mm-hmm
um the smiths the smiths were a big one
yes with hank wise yeah smith on the
pool deck
um a bunch of like ska and a little bit
of punk at the time fish bone
fish i saw fish modern concert many
times
yeah uh but i love wilco i mean yankee
hotel foxtrot is like a perfect album i
love radiohead
kid a okay computer or unbelievable for
rem
i i still love their earlier records
murmur reckoning
i just think they're genius um
and if you're gonna have the
conversation about best bands and best
albums i mean you gotta you gotta you
gotta you gotta throw the beatles in
there definitely
sergeant peppers um i love jeff buckley
i think his album grace is one that
finds its way onto
my recurring playlist i don't know man
what about you
i none of my top five would be
bands that uh except for maybe one would
be
or two that would be bands that i like i
grew up that they were my favorite band
at one point and then never stopped the
only the exception would be my favorite
which is bob marley in the whalers
um was my favorite the minute i heard
bob
and then has remained the top i think
most important band for me but other
than that i had like
my first favorite band was talking heads
then i got into bruce springsteen and
then like later i got into hip hop and
now i'm mostly listening to jazz to be
honest with you
uh but since the the the the question
i will give you my top five bands bob
marley and the whalers
david bowie jimi hendrix john coltrane
would be my favorite
uh jazz artist and then of course you
gotta put the beatles in there
because they're just you know
groundbreaking right um
songs i would do tangled up in blue by
bob dylan exodus by bob marley heroes by
bowie
voodoo child by hendricks and i love
supreme
these these selections are indicative of
somebody who's maybe
out of touch five to ten years older
than you actually are
yeah i'm i've i'm squarely uh gen
x are you even gen x i am what year were
you born 71
right so i'm on the older i'm on the
older uh
spectrum i'm right in the middle of gen
x but you know that doesn't mean so my
what i was trying to say is that my i'm
not one of those people that has top
five bands
mm-hmm i love all music and uh i love
world music i love rock i love all kinds
so
for me but if you had to pin me down and
i had to pick my top five bands like in
the spirit of this that's what i would
say but in reality
um i love all music i don't have a limit
and uh it used to be that i did but i
don't really anymore
and so i'm kind of open to all great
music
um and uh my
genre i listen to most is jazz to be
honest with you should we just you know
ditch everything that we've been doing
and just talk about like music and
movies on the podcast from now on out
you know what culture become become some
version of chuck klosterman
i'm gonna wait until the next google doc
and find out what i'm talking about
because you want to talk about whatever
i want to talk about adam don't you
um no that's not true we had a whole
thing do the work
are you doing the work out of course not
my whole philosophy is
don't believe everything you feel which
i know is bad that's probably not the
good
philosophy but i don't think that that's
bad i think
the caveat or the corollary to that that
i would say is
is that emotions
are your body and your interior
consciousness trying to tell you
something right
you can heed that message but i think we
often over index on those emotions and
and then you know kind of make it all
about that and the truth is
a lot of challenging emotions feel like
they're gonna kill you i'm gonna die
but emotions are always changing that's
the one thing that you can always bank
on it will always change
always change so feelings are just like
like sort of a corollary is like
feelings or just feelings
right that that and you don't have to
like they don't have they feel
like you know they feel so real but
essentially like you have a choice
how much you need to engage them
that's well that's the whole idea with
the stosis versus this
you know this new gen that worships
mental health uh
you know preservation whereas that's
where i depart from that because i
actually think
there's a lot of you know i see a lot of
people who are so into their mental
health and self-care and this and that
and they just become
paralyzed by it right i can't go to work
today right
i'm feeling a little bit blue right
right and it's like at some point
i'm not denigrating you you have to you
have to issue
no you have to reconcile appropriately
reconcile
uh responsible care for mental health
with the importance of of developing a
little bit of emotional resiliency yes
so yes yes all right let's do the last
question last question
i have this laptop here and i keep
putting my finger on the screen thinking
it's an ipad
you wanted to go laptops i know well
because it's just better with
opening links and there were some
articles i want to show you okay let's
hear from bev
bev hi rich and adam this is bev
from denver colorado i've had a long
running career that includes
three boston's while in my 50s my first
boston
was the year of the bomb and the only
marathon i didn't
finish anyway i'm 66 years old now and
i'm having difficulty
accepting the fact that i'm not as fast
as i was
and my feet can't take the longer
distances
my question is how to deal with the hard
facts of aging
and still set realistic goals that
excite me for the future
some days it's a real emotional and
physical challenge
thanks for any insights bye
thank you bev i feel a little insecure
trying to answer this question given the
fact that bev
is like 11 years older than me so she
probably has more wisdom and experience
about aging
than i do but my instinct my first
you know gut reaction to that question
is
that comparison is the thief of joy and
i think it's
um unrealistic and unfair to
compare yourself at 66 to
the way that you used to be able to run
i don't know how back into
you know far back into your history
you're you're casting your gaze but
essentially it goes to the answer
to the previous question which is about
acceptance like first
except that you're 66 years old right
now like let go
of this idea stop measuring yourself
against where you used to be or think
you should be
right like you're 66 there's certain
realities
about that right you're not you're going
to probably share my musical taste
probably yeah i would suspect that she
does so you could talk about hendrix and
coltrane
but the idea that you're comparing
yourself and judging yourself like
you're
you're you're creating you're creating
trauma for yourself by judging yourself
against a younger version i don't know
what age are you looking at
25 45 50. it's unclear
but essentially you're setting yourself
up to be disappointed
because you're 66 and you're not going
to be able to run as fast as you did
when you were in your 50s or 40s clearly
so
i think the best way to
like reckon with all of that is to make
peace with it
to train where you're at and focus on
you know where where you can find the
joy in all of it
you could still set goals and those
goals should be
you know difficult something you're
going to strive for but also realistic
given the given the fact that you know
you're 66
and just try to be the best 66 year old
version of yourself
because comparing yourself to a past
self again
is a comparison that robs you of of joy
it's a thief of joy
and honestly like you know truth talk
for a minute here
does anybody give a how fast you
run at 66.
no one cares the only person who
probably cares is you right
and it's important that you care that's
great
but um the weight that you're putting on
your times and all of that i think is
playing
into this heaviness that you're
experiencing around
running so why not alleviate yourself of
that pressure
go zone 2 baby go zone 2 and leave the
time's behind
right like holding on to i can't run as
fast as i used to
like is it worth it holding on to that
for the the kind of frustration that
it's causing you
no the consternation what about running
makes you happy
and orienting your goal around that i
think is a better
aim of your intentionality
if it's a performance if it's if it's
performance
that gets you out of bed in the morning
and excited then again you can set a
goal there's nothing wrong with setting
a performance goal but
don't set the goal you would have set
for yourself at age at age 40.
you know just remember if you sign up
for that 10k right now there are a bunch
of athletes running around in oval that
can do a 10k in 24 minutes
yeah it's shocking so you know what are
we talking about here
like what is it that got you falling in
love with running to begin with
and maybe find other ways that are not
performance related
to you know fine joy in it like the
travel like going to a race that's in a
cool place or
you know training with a community of
people or meeting new people etc there's
so much
there's so much richness in the sport of
running that it doesn't all have to be
about like prs
i got two words for you bev katsu
katsu that's right she's going to be all
about katsu and swimrun yeah but that's
going to get her all excited that maybe
she can maybe she could be
our marathon if she starts putting
tourniquets all over her body
katsu she's gonna call up steve munitano
get
get on the katsu and then go to wild
swim run camp where they get uh women of
all ages together
and do swim run camps where you can um
not worry about your time so much
because you're gonna also be integrating
some open water swimming
and believe me there are women of all
ages there are definitely women in your
area there's no indication in bev's
question that she has any interest in
swimming whatsoever
did i mention swim run yeah you did
oh am i not you had to bring in swimmers
you had to bring swimrun into this even
when
the podcast has nothing to do with swim
run there goes adam
bringing up swim run again yeah and
you're just you're just a shill
for you're a shill for big swim run
i'm saying for the low tide can't do
we're sending you checks
you can't do a marathon have you thought
of
swim run that's all i'm saying okay
do we answer this question i think we
need to end this
all right let's put a cap on it let's
land this plane let's do that
how do you feel i feel like i
i feel like i didn't deliver on these
questions
to be quite honest with you but you know
it's an emotion and i'll get over it
right it's impermanent feelings are just
feelings
feelings are just feelings these
olympics are going to you need to take a
mental health day
do i look like founding now like yeah if
you're like the next roll on i get a
phone call in the morning rich i can't
i can't record today i can't do it yeah
i can't do it i've been
i've been that feels snarky
what i didn't say it you said it no i'm
i'm reflecting on myself like i
literally we do need greater
appreciation for the nuances of mental
health in the workplace and
i feel like between the two of us you're
more into the like
mental health uh camp i'm more into the
you know try not to think about it cam
yeah it's a challenge
because you d you you do you do need
emotional resilience you need to develop
the capacity for showing up when things
are hard and you don't want to show up
so where do you strike that balance
that's that's really where the question
lies i think when the
jews were wandering desert for 40 years
there were the kvetchers
and then there were the people like me
that are just like try not to think
about it
i wasn't trying not to think about it
jew yeah i was not a
kavetcher kavetcher jew i was uh trying
not to think about a jew
that's what i am i'm like try not to
think about it a very specific
type subset yeah i'm a subset of the
desert people you don't want to sit
around and talk about it
all the permutations not only do i not
want to talk about it i don't want to
hear you
talk about it no one wants to hear it
anyway all right
i don't know what we're doing let's
let's end this all right listen
uh thank you adam that was fun i don't
know what we did today but we did
something
we wore tie-dye um you did yes if you
would like your
your question answered in a haphazard
and perhaps not helpful way
leave us a voicemail at 424-235-4626
uh show notes on the episode page at
richroll.com links to all the stuff we
talked about like matt fetterman's
article in the new york times etc
are all on the website you can check
that out there
dive deeper into everything we discussed
today please hit the subscribe button on
youtube
apple and spotify wherever you listen to
the show
and uh that's it call call leave us
leave us some questions guys
yeah leave us some good ones yeah um i
want to thank everybody who helped put
on the show today jason camiello for
audio engineering production
shona it's interstitial music
calendaring
uh i don't know taking care of the get
like he does all kinds of stuff
here lots of stuff thank you stops
people from sawing outside our doorway
he does
yes he's johnny on the spot when there's
a noise outside he runs outside and
rectifies it post haste posthaste
uh blake curtis for videoing and editing
the podcast
it's a lot of work thank you blake he's
the one who
makes all of this look so cool jessica
miranda for graphics
today we have um grayson grayson wilder
on portraits thank you grayson georgia
whaley
for copywriting dk for advertiser
relationships theme music by my boys
tyler trapper
and harry appreciate all of you i don't
take your attention for granted
and i'll see you back here in a couple
days with another awesome
episode we have courtney dewalters up
this week just went up
i think who's going up in a couple i
think it's eric adams
really new york city's next mayor
incredible
yeah man runners mayors all kinds of
people
you know bruce friedrich clean frederick
out of work journalists you get them all
all right man i need a two-week break
from you i'll see you in two weeks
are we in a timeout right now no we're
not in a timeout well i guess we are at
a time yeah we're gonna hit we're gonna
hit timeout and we'll see you in two
weeks
i'm gonna talk to other people while
we're are you you're not allowed that's
not part of our contract
[Laughter]
all right man all right love you you too
man peace plants
[Music]
you